hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and in this video I'm going to give you
some step-by-step really practical
advice on how to achieve Financial
Freedom in 12 months or less now this is
2 30 year 2022. I became financially
free oh my goodness when I was 21 I'm
now 31 so a decade ago and after I
became financially free I spent the you
know I spent a lot of time traveling I
built a lot of big businesses I made
many millions of pounds in property and
this is a video basically summarizing
and condensing how I really got started
and I'm going to give you the formulas
to First breaking through that Financial
Freedom Milestone so I hope you enjoyed
this video I hope you find it really
helpful I think the very first thing
that people struggle with with becoming
financially free is they don't actually
know what Financial Freedom means so I'm
going to give you a few steps to
achieving it but the first thing is
actually defining what Financial Freedom
means to you because if you wanna if you
want to achieve a goal let's say you
want to go somewhere in a car
if you're not clear and specific on
where you want to go you're not going to
get there and people come to me all the
time saying I want to get rich I want to
be financially free but what does it
actually mean if you type into a Sat Nav
take me somewhere Sunny take me you know
to a hot place take me to Financial
Freedom it's like what what does it mean
so the very first thing is to Define
what it means for you and for me what
Financial Freedom means is for a star it
means passive income now passive income
is very different to active income I'd
rather you give me a thousand pounds a
month of passive income then give me a
hundred thousand pounds cash in my bank
today because let me explain passive
income is money that comes in every
month whether you go to work or whether
you don't passive income is like for
instance if you own a property and
you're renting that property out and
you're getting an income from the
property but you're not having to go to
work for the income you've you've got
the house if you buy a house you own the
house forever so forever as long as
you've got a tenant in there you're
going to be getting an income so that's
passive income active income's very
different active income is when you've
got to go to work you've effectively got
to trade your time for money and if
you're exchanging your time for money
you'll never get rich so passive income
and how I Define Financial Freedom is my
first goal was to cover my living
expenses in passive income I thought
right right now if I've got my rent and
my food and my car and my life paid for
in passive income then I'm financially
free now the exciting thing is
all right might not be something for you
but the exciting thing for me was at the
time I'm thinking well I don't need to
actually earn any more money right now
if you're making two grand a month okay
or three grand a month rather than
thinking I need to make more money I
need to make 10 grand a month or 20
grand I need to become a millionaire
maybe you need to earn the same money or
maybe a little bit more but just a
different type of income because when I
was 21 I wasn't making a huge amount of
money I was making about six thousand
pounds a month which is a good income
and was a very good income at the time
but that money was coming in every month
from my from my rent it was passive and
it meant that I wasn't living a life of
absolute luxury but I truly believe that
the best things in life
are free they don't cost anything but
they may as well cost the Earth if you
haven't got the time to enjoy them me
right now just sitting in my garden on
the hammock enjoying the sunshine it's
not costing me any money right after
after I've finished shooting this video
I'm going to go off with my kids we're
going to go to the park with my wife and
my three kids going to the park doesn't
cost any money walking along along the
beach and looking up at the stars and
the best things in life don't really
cost that much money last night I went
to The Lion King I went to the theater
show The Lion King we had a great night
out it didn't cost that much money so
people think I need more money I need
more money but what they really need is
they need more time and the way that
they're going to get more time is
through passive income so first step is
to Define what passive income is and how
much passive income you need
to be financially free so I want you to
write that figure down I want you to be
really clear on how much passive income
do you need in order to be financially
free maybe it's five grand ten Grand 15
grand I don't know but the second step
this is the interesting one is to
simplify that figure
if you want to be financially free it
might be that you're spending three
you're making three grand a month at the
moment but it's possible that if you go
through your bank statements there's
things that you're spending money on
that you actually don't need to spend
money on you know I was working with one
of my students and he was saying to me I
need I need five grand a month I said
okay we went through his bank statements
he was paying for a gym membership he
hadn't been for nine months he was
paying for a dating agency subscription
he was now married you know it's just
like and he was like what's this I was
like what's this what's this what's this
it's like I don't actually know I don't
know so we went through we canceled a
bunch of his standing orders we canceled
a bunch of his direct debits we
simplified his expenditures as low as we
could with with not massively affecting
his life we cut you know certain costs
down and it he went from saying I need
five grand to I need three grand
so that's the second step simplify your
expenditures you can live a simple life
and you can live a good and a free life
so
the first thing is passive income what
is it second thing is how much do you
need then how much can you bring that
down to and then the third step is let's
say right now you're thinking I need two
grand a month in passive income the
third thing you need to do is you need
to absolutely ingrain on your brain that
figure
and set out to earn that figure in
passive income and you could do this a
number of ways you could do this by if
you haven't got the money to start
buying properties and investing huge
amounts of money because making two
grand a month you don't need I mean if
you've got a few hundred thousand pounds
you can just invest that into regular
property investing and the rental income
will make you financially free if you've
not got a hundred thousand pounds to
start with then you can do things like
rent to rent so you can rent properties
but then rent them out a much higher
amount by splitting them up or putting
them on Airbnb with obviously the right
permission in place that's then going to
give you a recurring passive income if
you structure it right so two grand
three grand four grand whatever it is
you need to start thinking forget
replacing or exchanging my time with
money forget trying to work harder how
can I work smarter how can I make the
same amount of money but in passive
income and once you do that and you get
to the point whereby you don't need to
go to work anymore then guess what
you're not rich but you're financially
free and when you're financially free
you know you can do with all your time
go get rich do what you love and
hopefully leave the world a better place
than you found it
[Music]